Вітаю українців.
Європа стала до вас ближчою. Подорожуйте.
Не усі українці вірять в те, що подорожувати без віз
буде легше.
В соцмережах поширюється думка,
що із "безвізом" паперового клопоту стане іще більше.
Тільки замість посольств і візових центрів
цілі стоси документів та грошові збори
вимагатимуть від українців вже прикордонники.
Ось типовий коментар:
DW вирішила порахувати.
Нині для отримання віз в країни Шенгену
посольства вимагають такі документи:
Підтвердження про укорінення в Україні,
довідку з роботи або з податкової,
довідку з навчального закладу,
свідоцтво про одруження, про народження дітей, що залишаються в Україні,
про майнові права, довідку з ЖЕКу.
Підтвердження фінансової спроможності,
копії українського та закордонного паспортів,
поліс медстрахування,
запрошення та копію паспорту особи, яку ви маєте намір відвідати.
Також можуть вимагати
підтвердження бронювання житла, авіаквитки в обидва боки
та план маршруту.
Подаючи документи, усі подорожуючі здають і біометричні дані.
Близько 30 євро бере за послуги візовий центр,
сама ж віза коштує віз 20 до 125 євро
залежно від виду та країни.
З 11 червня,
відколи набуде чинності безвізовий режим
між Україною та ЄС,
подорожувати стане значно простіше.
Скасовуються плата за послуги візового центру та за саму візу.
Із документів необхідно мати
новий біометричний паспорт, або ж звичайний закордонний паспорт з діючою візою.
Більше не потрібні довідки з роботи,
з ЖЕКу, про володіння нерухомістю,
свідоцтва про одруження, народження дітей тощо.
На європейському кордоні можуть попросити
такі документи:
Запрошення від приймаючої сторони або бронювання житла.
План поїздки та зворотний квиток.
Підтвердження фінансової спроможності.
У разі сумнівів можуть попросити пред'явити наявність коштів
на кредитній картці міжнародного зразка.
Тож з 11 червня
можна забути про грошові збори та стоси паперів,
які українці зазвичай несли
до візових центрів та посольств.